[Music]
dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with karoly zsolnai-feher if we
would like to see how digitally modeled
objects would look like in real life we
would create a 3d model of the desired
scene assign material models to the
objects within and use a photorealistic
rendering algorithm to finish the job it
simulates rays of light that connect the
camera to the light sources in the scene
and compute the flow of energy between
them initially after a few rays we'll
only have a rough idea on how the image
should look like therefore our initial
results will contain a substantial
amount of noise
we can get rid of this by simulating the
path of millions and millions of rays
that will eventually clean up our image
this process where a noisy image gets
clearer and clearer we call convergence
and the problem is that this can take
excruciatingly long even up to hours to
get a perfectly clear image
with the simpler algorithms out there we
generate these light paths randomly this
technique we call path tracing however
in the scene that you see here most
random paths can connect the camera and
the light source because this wall is in
the way obstructing many of them light
paths like these don't contribute
anything to our calculations and are
ultimately a waste of time and precious
resources
after generating hundreds of random
light paths we have found a path that
finally connects the camera with a light
source without any obstructions when
generating the next path it will be a
crime not to use this knowledge to our
advantage a technique called metropolis
light transport will make sure to use
this valuable knowledge and upon finding
a bright light path it will explore
other paths that are nearby to have the
best shot at creating valid unobstructed
connections if we have a difficult scene
at hand metropolis light transport gives
us way better results than traditional
completely random path sampling
techniques such as path tracing here are
some equal time comparisons against path
tracing to show how big of a difference
this technique makes an equal time
comparison means that we save the output
of two algorithms that will run for the
same amount of time on the same scene
and see which one performs better
this scene is extremely difficult in a
sense that the only source of light is
coming from the upper left and after the
light goes through multiple glass
spheres most of the light paths that we
generate will be invalid as you can see
the random path tracer yields really
dreadful results well if you can call a
black imager result that is and as you
can see metropolis light transport is
extremely useful in these cases
and here's the beautiful completely
cleaned up converge result
the lead author of this technique eric
veach won a technical oscar award for
his work one of which was metropolis
light transport
if you like the series please click on
that subscribe button to become a fellow
scholar thanks for watching there are
millions of videos out there and you
decided to take your time with this one
that is amazing thank you and i'll see
you next time